please join me in welcoming David member
for a talk entitled the library as a
data set text mining at million books
gale welcome
thank you for the introduction as you
heard i I'm a computer scientist so you
might be wondering why am I on the
digital humanities initiative committee
at Princeton what do I bring their my
expertise is in algorithms and scalable
inference for for large-scale
probabilistic models and I think that
the answer to that what I hope I can
contribute is the methodologies that
humanists can use to make use of the
enormous amount of digital resources and
and the advances in probabilistic
inference that have occurred over the
last 10 years so that just to give you
an outline of where I'm going here I'm
going to start by talking a bit about
the digital humanities but very briefly
and then I'm going to go into a
particular method that that I've got a
experience in which is statistical topic
modeling have people heard of this
before some of you okay and then I'm
going to go through a case study on 19th
century novels where I am like my
colleague Matt jockers at the University
of Nebraska were able to apply this
statistical method to particular
questions that he has as a scholar of
English literature going to talk a bit
about digital humanities first and I
would say that the way that I really
think of the role of digital humanities
is not as Greg said or agree with Greg
not to create a new discipline but to
make computing as vital in humanities
and Social Sciences as it is in
engineering and science and and the way
I kind of visualize that is in every
University I've been to there's always
this sort of imaginary boundary at
Princeton it's Washington Road
sort of diagonal street if you're if
you're east of washington road then
computing means simulating the plasma in
a fusion reactor or modeling the global
climate our looking at the entire human
genome if you're west of washington road
computing means microsoft word and and
if there's anything that that i feel
that i want to contribute over my career
it's it's to change that to make
computing as vital west of washington
road as it is east so what is the
digital humanities this this is kind of
the picture that I want people to avoid
it's that you take some humanities and
you scan it and you get digital
humanities and you can think of this as
to sort of phases and the first phase in
digital humanities is exactly that that
digitization phase and there is an
enormous number of very important and
very very impactful questions that you
have to answer when you're digitizing I
mean it really matters getting this
right but what's important and and what
the real impact of this type of
technology is on this on the right that
this what I call phase two other people
break this into three waves it this is
the way I think of it that digital
technology should be part of the
methodology for humanistic inquiry for
social science inquiry so if you look
through the Yale course catalog there's
probably a lot of classes that are
something like research methods for
biology or research methods for
sociology a lot of fields have
particular ways of making measurements
and understanding the meaning of those
measurements when I've asked humanists
like do you have the equivalent of this
and there really isn't one there is no
research methods for English and one of
the possibilities of incorporating
digital technologies as an organic part
of a discipline not as a separate thing
is to have a suite of research methods
ways of making
measurements and thinking about that the
meaning of those measurements that can
make the difference between using
technologies as a sort of thing and and
using technology as an assumption it's
just something that you do at some point
in the process that you work in so I
want to talk a bit about this particular
statistical model that that I work with
statistical topic modeling and I want to
describe that the reason that a lot of
humanists and people outside that the
sort of traditional people who are
interested in statistics the reason
they've been interested in this is that
it it addresses a couple problems that
really get to the core interest of
humanists now as I said on the computer
scientists so I'm always on thin ice
when I talk about the real interests of
humanists but but something that's
that's that's had a lot of resonance
with people that I've talked to is that
humanists want to take a big body of
historical material and look at it and
say what happened and there's two real
big problems that people are always
facing first there's too much stuff you
cannot possibly read everything that
there is you cannot process it you
cannot use the methods that that people
have been using it's just too big and
it's only getting bigger the second is
that there's there's an incredibly hard
process of getting away from the biases
from from the preconceptions from the
stories that have built up about the
past you know as Daniel Kahneman says
that the world makes much less sense
than you think it does our brain is this
amazing engine from for taking noisy
crazy data and making it coherent story
and one of the hardest things that that
human of space is trying to get back to
the real messy fact of what really
happened and away from these clean
stories and so a lot of people were very
excited to see this it people recognize
this this tool this is the google ngram
viewer it's a collaboration between
google and some some folks at harvard
and what you can do is put in a word or
phrase this is just their stock example
and you get back wiggly lines that show
you the frequency of that word or phrase
in several million books from that the
period where the statistics are kind of
accurate is about 1800 to the present
day and so a lot of people said ah this
is what we've been looking for first of
all it looks at everything this is
millions of books we're not making
decisions about what we can read second
it is in some way objective for as
objective as possible because it's just
counting things but there's a couple
problems the first one is that even
though this is theoretically based on
everything you're still looking through
this tiny keyhole of a single word or a
single phrase and you have to come up
with that phrase yourself there might be
ten a hundred a thousand other words
that are interesting to your research
question but if you don't know about
them you're not going to find them the
second problem is a little more subtle
and I like to give this example my
colleague at Princeton in the digital
humanities initiative Meredith Martin
she was reading this book about the rise
and fall of meter Meredith asked me to
mention that this book is on the shelves
I can give the Amazon link if you'd like
and and as you can see Meredith is very
much in this tradition of taking
something that we think we know and
showing that that we really don't know
that much about it that there's a lot
more complexity things were happening in
in in overlapping periods there and
she's trying to get away from the patent
narratives that we moved and hand it
down and so she was really interested in
these digital met these word search
methods when they came out and so she
did a search on several words and found
that there was
an unusual spike in the word syntax and
prosody in 1823 Angie Tata ha some event
or some cultural trigger has has led to
a spirited debate about meter or poetics
in 1823 so we need to find out more
about this turns out syntax and prosody
where the name with two famous race
horses and as you can see prosody one
very easy that there were really fast
horses and people were writing about
them all the time in 1823 so this is
both incredibly depressing and also very
encouraging because it's depressing
because this should be the best-case
syntax prosody these are about the most
specific concrete single meaning words
that you're going to get these are
highly technical vocabulary and even in
this case we can't get away from the
racehorse problem but it's encouraging
because if anyone who speaks even a
modicum of English looks at this page
there is no question that this is about
poetry or meter or syntax or linguistics
this is definitely about race horses so
the intuition that we get and I think
the reason that a lot of people are
interested in in the type of method I
work with is that context is vital to
meaning and it is not enough to simply
search for the string PR 0 s 0 dy
occurring in books we need to look at
prosody within particular contexts so
let's get back to the type of method
that that I work with in text mining
let's say we'd have three these three
documents and sowed in news stories you
could you could classify these maybe you
have labels already maybe you could put
them on and say that the one on the left
is probably about sports and the one on
the right is probably you could call it
business and the one the bottom may be
organized labor
the question becomes how many categories
do you apply so this document here
cablevision signs deal to carry NFL
network is that sports or is a business
well it's kind of both so I guess I
should really just create a new category
business of sports and then what if I
get okay talks between NFL referee stall
that's kind of sports labor okay I add
one more category of okay GM plants hit
by UIW strike okay that's another
category and it goes on and on you can
kind of see how it's set this up that
there's there's really not a single
category for each document it can be
better represented not best represented
but better represented as combinations
of three simpler categories three themes
sports business and labor and when way
to think of this is that we're not
applying labels to documents as a whole
we're applying labels two words and so I
can go in using my domain knowledge and
color each of the words in these
documents by their their their theme and
I could say that maybe okay the in the
top right General Motors earnings fall
that's that's kind of one hundred
percent business and that the one in the
bottom right GM plants hit by UAW strike
that I can count the words that I've
assigned to the different themes and say
that it's about forty percent the blue
theme and sixty percent the green theme
and to get back to the ideas of
contextual disambiguation let's say I
say that that document on the top left
is pretty much one hundred percent about
sports and there's a word somewhere in
the middle that is a field so is this a
playing field or a magnetic field or
some other type of field well I don't
really have full natural language
understanding that that's you know a
hundred years out in a Pai research but
I can decide whether I want to put that
word filled with the sports theme or
with the magnetism and physics theme and
I can get clues about what what choice I
should make by looking at the other
words in the document so if most of the
words in that document I've put in the
red category then probably I should also
put that ambiguous word in the red
category so if I have all the words in
my library painted like this put into
different categories different themes
then I should be able to look for the
word field in the context of sports or
field in the context of magnetism and
get some degree of disambiguation much
better than we had before again none of
this is perfect there's a lot more
research to be done but it's an
improvement and I could also do things
like if I had all these words call it in
like that then I could count up all of
the blue words make a list of all my
distinct words and create these little
word frequency tables so for example the
blue category it's gotten a very large
number of the word company slightly less
CEO slightly less earnings and I can
represent that category by looking at
those most most frequently occurring
words all right so you might be
wondering who is going to do this word
labeling there's no way anyone can do it
by hand we have to resort to approximate
inference and statistical machine
learning and I gave a talk in in
computer science yesterday where I
made my best effort to explain how we do
it I'm not going to spare you that
suffice it to say that that we can do
this we can take large numbers of texts
that are just documents with no labels
whatsoever and give you a representation
that that's something like this so we
put each word into one of some number of
different categories we don't know what
the categories are beforehand we only
know what the most frequent words and
those categories are we don't want know
what the labels of the documents are
beforehand we just we just get the
documents and that's the key to
scalability and so this is what brings
me to the library scale topic models so
I have a collection of 1.2 million OCR
outputs from from pre-1920 two out of
copyright books please don't sue me
they're all okay if I remove the non
interesting words and the low frequency
words we're non interesting into the end
of that sort of thing there's still
about thirty three billion unique tokens
now the vocabulary size about 65,000 and
I can get an output that looks like the
thing on the right the way to read this
is each row is the most frequent words
in a theme or topic so what you see is
that so that that first theme the most
frequent word is killed second most
frequent wounded and sword slain arms
military and you can see that that the
contents of this collection are fairly
well summarized by this so there's
there's there's themes about war there's
things about philosophy there's a lot of
medicine there's see travel sister child
tears pleasure daughter loves and
there's sort of family words being happy
and sad and this is this is a a machine
representation of the contents of these
1.2 million books so we also have all
the catalog records but this is a
different way of looking at the contents
alright so that's the method as a whole
that that's what we can do in the
computer science department the question
for a humanist is what can they use that
method for so how can they incorporate
it into their research methodology how
can they do the things that they want to
do find out what happens during
particular historical period in ways
that that are that are that are as
objective as possible and take into
account as much information as possible
so I'm going to show you a case study on
a subset of the the open source or the
idea at the open book collection these
are 19th century novels we've narrowed
the focus down from those 1.2 million
books to 3346 novels these are by
british irish and american authors there
are male authors females and unknown
authors that there's been a fair amount
of work done on identifying author
gender so we know that George Eliot is
female for example there's a there's a
slightly more male authors and there's a
smaller but significant collection of
authors for which we really do not know
their gender the texts if you if you
model books as a whole you get kind of
washed-out results so we break the books
in two thousand word chunks and we also
removed this is after a lot of trial and
error we found that the method worked
best when we removed all words except
nouns that were not personal names
because if you have a novel and you're
looking for words that co-occur together
which is what this method really is you
get character names and you know the
title disambiguate skerrick turn
we don't need that so we had some
questions the first is does this do the
discover themes and topics even make any
sense for this collection previously
topic models have mostly been applied to
scientific articles news articles that
kind of thing where where they're really
about something in their specific
technical vocabulary so the question was
could we even do this on novels would it
make sense second we wanted to take an
external variable or external to the
texts like the author gender and say can
we find relationships between that
external variable maybe it's gender
maybe its nationality maybe it's year of
publication and the choice of themes in
a novel and finally we were really
interested in what we could say about
the anonymous authors so one theory that
that most people think of first is that
oh they're all women because because of
the society they lived in they were not
able to publish under their own names
another possibility which well the other
another possibility is that there is no
difference there they're just randomly
people who don't want to publish under
their names another possibility is that
they are people who are writing about
things that they do not feel comfortable
about and are deliberately withholding
their names not because of who they are
but because of what they're writing so
that's a hypothesis that we want to test
and finally and what this is the real
story of this talk are these results
meaningful does the fact that we can
measure something mean that we've got a
result or does it just mean that we can
apply a function to data so let's look
at some examples I'm going to read some
of these words because I imagine that a
little difficult to read this is a topic
that we've labeled by hand female
fashion but the most frequent words are
dress silk gown lace hair
muslin ribbon if you look you can go
quite far down in the word frequency
list so dressing-gown slipper millinery
damsel plumes frizzy and garment it this
is a pretty clean topic another one
enemies this that that's the human
generated label that's what we looked at
this and said this is this is a label
that we're just gonna refer to this
enemy cavalry front charged pursuit
general speed campaign rifles bivouac
again this looks fairly fairly solid and
a third one which we've labeled convents
and Abby's convent Abbess monastery
walls cloister protection length
crucifix difficulty secrets austerities
superstition again we're pretty happy
with with the themes that we're getting
out so that's kind of the first question
we think this is a reasonable method to
use on this text collection but the
second question is can we measure the
association between a variable like
gender and the choice of which theme to
use the way we do that let's let's make
the data set much simpler and let's say
we only have five novels we can make a
table like this for a particular topic
let's let's take the enemy's topic and
the way to read this is that the first
book is by mail author and twenty
percent of the words in that book we are
algorithm has assigned to this topic
which we are calling enemies second book
authors male thirty percent of those the
words in that book are assigned to the
enemy's topic in the bottom one we don't
know the author fifteen percent of the
words or a son to the topic eighty-five
percent are assigned to something else
so they did these are not supposed to
some 20 these are distinct volumes each
of which has its own number and we can
take all of the male authors all the
female authors and all
unknown authors and and get the average
of their proportion so what is the mean
percent use of the topic among a certain
category of authors and we can plot that
and so this is the the female fashion
topic that the left column is female
authors the middle column is male
authors in the right column is unknown
authors so a few things to note first of
all female authors tend to use this
female fashion topic more than male
authors that was not a surprise to us
but it's it's sort of reassuring and in
the calibration sense that that we
expect to get this result for this
particular topic and yes indeed we did
get it the second thing to note is that
if we think about our hypotheses about
who these unknown authors are if the
hypothesis that the authors were not
releasing their names because they were
female if that were correct then we'd
expect that unknown dot to be closer to
the female dom but it's not it's
somewhere in the middle so that's that's
evidence against the hypothesis that all
of the unknown authors are female ok
let's look at this is the enemy's topic
we see the reverse male authors use this
much more than female authors unknowns
are in between all right here's the
convent San Abby's topic and here's
something that really caught our eye
so female authors use it more than male
authors unknown authors seem to use it a
lot more than either of those so this is
a case where the unknown authors are not
a linear combination of the male and
female authors day or doing something
else so we want to know what's going on
here all right the first question that
we have is are these results meaningful
and here are three ways to ask the same
question so does the difference that we
measured reflect a real distinction
between male and female authors or is it
just an artifact of a small sample size
so we're calculating numbers i scaled it
so that one was on the bottom when one
was on the top is that a real
distinction or is it just that they
happen to be one way or another if there
were no real difference what is the
probability that we would see a result
that had as big a difference of that
that's that's basically the same
question or another way to put it is we
want to distinguish between a pattern
and randomness if we want to do that we
have to understand what randomness looks
like so how do we do that there's a
method that goes back to a fissure in
the 30s but was published in the 50s of
this this is not new science what we're
saying with this test or with this
experiment is we want to know whether
there's a relationship between that
gender column and the topic proportion
column we're saying that one predicts
the other so in order to know what it
would look like if there was no
predictive ability if there was no
connection we can create a random or an
alternative universe where we scramble
that middle column so here's a here's an
alternate universe where wilkie
collins's female Dickens is still male
we don't know who Jane Austen is George
Eliot actually is male and and this
unknown author is female so there's
still the same number of male and female
authors we've kept the sample size the
same but we've scrambled the
relationship between those two columns
we can do the same thing count up all
the female authors all them
l authors and say what would that
statistic look like what would those
three where would those three points be
in this alternate universe where there's
no connection and we can do that a
thousand times because that's just
scrambling data it takes about two
seconds and we can plot that same plot
that I showed you before for each of
those thousand replications and compare
it to the real data it looks something
like this so each of the gray dots is a
fake universe the black dots are the
same date of you saw before the the side
to side is just random jitter so that
you can actually see all the points and
what you see is that the actual black
points that that we observed are way
outside the range of any of these
replications under under the assumption
that there's no no correlation between
the two columns so we're very confident
that female authors and male authors use
this topic at different rates the
unknown authors are sort of within the
range that we would expect if there was
no real correlation if you've heard
about p-values the p-value means how
many gray dots are below the black dot
what proportion of them look at the
enemy's topic similar but this is a less
a slightly less significant result you
know it's still definitely not random
but there there it were closer to the
even distribution all right convents and
Abbey's our result from before holds up
we're excited just the the usage is
about consistent it's unusual but it's
kind of consistent with with the null
hypothesis unknown authors are way above
all right significance part two we were
pretty happy at this point but we wanted
to try a different test and and that the
question we were asking before is does
the pattern that we saw look like what
we'd expect if there was no actual
difference between male and female
authors now what we want to know is okay
keep all the male and female authors
mail it
email but how much variability is there
within each category how much does the
number that we saw depend on the
specific set of data that we saw or is
it the result of the influence of large
outliers so do this we do something
called bootstrap testing this is also a
fairly well-established method this is
their original data and what we're going
to do is keep the middle column exactly
the same so we have the same number of
male authors same number of female
authors saying unknowns and we're going
to just written erase the other columns
and then we're going to create a new
fake data set where for every row we're
going to take a random if the gender is
male will take a random male author so
we get Wilkie Collins and then for the
next row would take another random male
author oh we got lucky we also got
Wilkie Collins again so we now we have
two wilkie collins's in this data set we
go through and then we recalculate again
all right so that that's maybe not that
interesting for this data set but what
if this was the original data set so
woka columns in 75% Dickens is five
percent there's a big gap if we do our
bootstrap test and we happen to get to
wilkie collins's we'll get a result
that's a mean of 75 percent which is
much bigger than the forty percent we
got before if we get lucky and happy to
get to Dickens's we've got five percent
which is much lower than what we got
before so what we should see is if the
category is fairly homogeneous if it
doesn't matter who you get within a
category then the points that we get
from replications should be fairly
tightly clustered around the actual
point that we observed if they're
outliers we should get a big spread so
here's what we get the female fashion
again these results are pretty good at
supporting our hypothesis that there's a
difference between usage females that
there's a
bit more wiggle than males males just
don't really use this topic very much
and they're very consistent about that
compare that to the enemy's topic here
that females you know there's even less
variability but there's a lot more
variability among males so some male
authors are writing a lot about conflict
and armed conflict others are not
writing about it at all and depending on
how many of those war books we get will
either get a lot of percentage about
enemies or not so much unknown authors
are kind of in the middle all right
here's where we started get a little
worried so this is the convent San
Abby's topic female authors very tightly
clustered male authors very tightly
clustered unknown authors all over the
place and so at this point we went back
and looked more carefully at the data
and discovered that there were two books
in the unknown category that had an
unusually high concentration of convents
and Abbey's and what was worse one of
them wasn't even unknown it was an
abridgment of an an radcliffe novel that
had been marketed without her name on it
and so we were hoping that we would come
up with a grand big conclusion about the
identity of unknown authors what we
ended up with was maybe more of a
cautionary tale but we think that this
type of skeptical approach to
constitutive methods is perhaps more
exciting than some great new finding
about 19th century novels because it
shows that we can say things with a lot
of confidence but we can also use these
methods use these randomization tests
bootstrap tests other other tests to
check ourselves and keep ourselves from
being seduced by these beautiful
hypotheses
so kind of to bring this together
measuring the use of themes is a very
powerful tool but it's not enough by
itself we have to check the significance
of those results and absolutism some
more philosophical points here the one
that I really want to point out is that
this was a this work was a collaboration
between myself in the computer science
department and Matt jockers who's an
English professor neither of us could
have done this on our own I don't really
know that much about 19th century novels
he doesn't know that much about
randomization tests we both know a lot
more now but it was really a
collaboration between specialists and
also i think that the real goal of
digital humanities going to bring this
back to the beginning is is invisibility
that we need to to make digital methods
and and methodologies a part of the
standard tool kit that everyone has you
don't have to use them you can do
whatever you want but it's not it's not
a thing it's a it's a tool that everyone
should have access to so just to close
with some some credits I really could
not have done any of this without the
high performance computing group at
Princeton they were the first people I
talked to who I said I want four
terabytes and they said okay also the
computing research in association funds
me I couldn't do this without them and
also the digital humanities initiative
at Princeton is a really exciting group
and we're hoping to to collaborate a lot
with digital humanities at Yale so thank
you very much
informal on but perhaps we can have one
question for our speaker David and then
perhaps others can just come up and talk
to the speakers before we give them
their lunch as a reward for joining us
today that's why I do this yes free
lunches
why yes Greg so what Greg's referring to
is if you if you have a collection where
you have links between translations or
even comparable documents for example
Wikipedia also often has articles that
have links to this to not a translation
of the article but the same theme then
you can align models across languages
and measure the use of a theme in
different literature's in ways that you
couldn't before
manatees throughout here